(fast-paced, bouncy violin music)
- [Narrator] Before the
cowboys of the Wild West,
there were Hungary's Csikós,
horseman of the Puszta,
Hungary's Great Plain.
There way of life is centuries-old
and blends tradition with
death-defying riding.
They are some of Europe's
greatest horsemen.
- [Narrator] The Csikós
are tasked with caring
for the region's horses and cattle
using centuries-old techniques.
- [Narrator] Adam's father,
János, has been a Csikós
for 35 years, the first in the family.
Adam followed in his father's footsteps.
- [Narrator] The riders
live in relative isolation
on ranches that dot the plains.
Only a few Csikós are left in the region,
and it's becoming
difficult to keep the ways
of the horseman alive.
(lively acoustic music)
(chiming)